[Applause]
[Music]
last week's new releases was all about
the nintendo switch and now it's time to
give some love to the other consoles
that can't be played on the toilet but
no matter where you prefer to play hit
that subscribe button to stay up to date
on all the hottest games here's what's
marching in this week I promise I have
better puns than that the drug trade is
a problem and blowing stuff up and Ghost
Recon wildlands is the solution the
tactical shooter drops you into a
massive open world bolivia with a whole
cartel of thugs and captains and
lieutenants to take down you can
approach the missions with stealth or go
guns blazing play solo or with friends
and complete objectives in whatever
order you want bolivia is one of the
biggest Maps Ubisoft has ever created
and there's a ton of different
environments to conquer from jungles to
deserts to giant mountains you can
parachute in when Ghost Recon wildlands
comes to ps4 xbox one and pc on tuesday
march seven the nintendo switch already
got all the attention last week but
snipper eclipse is a puzzle game worth
looking back for and just like with
Ghost Recon you're going to want to play
with a friend whenever your little paper
guys overlap you can cut out that
section of your character a flatter
shape lets you balance objects but
filing to a point lets you poke at
things and even pop balloons you don't
have to wait to get started either since
snipper clips is out right now and for
more switch talk you can check out our
final impressions of nintendo's new
console on the lobby gamespot's weekly
live show every wednesday at 11am
pacific if you'd rather play an RPG then
solve puzzles attili a furious has you
covered this is the 18th game in the
series and it brings back the time limit
mechanic fighting battles crafting items
and exploring the world all consume time
and you've got one year to complete your
main quest you can take four heroes into
combat and the cooldown time between
turns is based on what attacks you
choose stack the right moves and you
unleash some pretty powerful combo
attacks ottilie a furious released in
japan and 2016 but it's coming to the
west on ps4 PS vita and pc on march
seven speaking of games coming west near
automata is the follow-up to the cult
classic action RPG near the sequel comes
from Platinum Games the minds behind
vanquish in Bayonetta and it shows the
playable androids fight with a variety
of heavy and light attacks dodges and
counters and the more you fight the
stronger you grow letting you customize
your Android's internal chips to change
your health and other powers and
considering the bosses we've seen you're
going to need those buffs near automata
comes exclusively to ps4 on March
seventh with a PC release also planned
for later this year for something a
little less violent why not check out
Lego world's if you've played the other
Lego games featuring Batman or Star Wars
you're in for something different this
time around Lego world lets you build
your own world out of the bricks you
collect you'll still find plenty of
studs and special objects but it all
funnels into building whatever you want
out of predefined structures or a
totally free form brick by brick system
houses vehicles custom terrain anything
you can picture you can build Lego
world's comes to ps4 xbox one and pc on
march seventh with a nintendo switch
version also in the works and those are
the big games will be playing this week
as always remember that release dates
are based on retailer listings enter
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and I'll see you next time
you